[Musique]
c'est quel genre d'aéronef ça j'ai
jamais rien vu de pareil petit clair
on notre monde tout entier étant danger
il faut absolument que tu m'accompagnes
en expédition je ne suis pas mon père
c'était lui l'explorateur je sais que tu
étais jeune quand il a été porté
disparaît mais aujourd'hui tu es notre
seul espoir
je suis un gros phare merci de votre
père vous me feriez un autographe en
imitant sa signature
[Musique]
mais enfin on est où là
on est manifestement en terre inconnue
[Musique]
bonjour vous devez pas comprendre ce mot
de ce que je dis c'est bon qu'est-ce que
tu crois je suis pas sourd papa
grand-père je suis grand-père
c'est quoi cet endroit il fallait son
vivant
ça te va bien vu que tu as une tête
toute plate
d'accord je les mérité
grand-père est génial il a rien de
génial tu m'as offert une machette pour
mon anniversaire ça c'est moi tout
craché j'avais deux ans
cette petite réunion de famille est
touchante mais en attendant on a un
monde à sauver
il faut que vous trouviez une solution
sinon on est tous morts on est tous
morts non c'est vrai
je l'ai pas vu venir
[Musique]